hello and welcome to this video playing
loop a rupee I don't know let's let's do
something else here and since we can and
doing the Kings engineer ok that the h3
line here hmm can I do something else
let's just play conservatively
I also play the H line age three line
quite off normally with a night being on
f3 here there are a couple of more
options for white you can also go for an
ige to base set up
yeah I think you have to go f5 him for
going to play yeah normally white is
just take on f5 maybe f3 I don't know
would be a bit unusual but I can take we
have seven okay that doesn't inspire
much confidence
interesting
hmm and it's interesting because i have
also f4 here in this position for Queen
g6 or queen g6 immediately
let's do that sure ways going with the
bishop we should be three days f4 that's
no good
oh ok but now well wait wait wait he lay
a couple of problems with this is also
night before and that's F for this is
looks pretty annoying actually just to
take this ok I think yeah I probably
just check here right now check here if
to a saying with check
k interesting hmm
hmm I'm not sure if I like him to t1c
five years that's not what I wanted
yeah let's go here yeah I wasn't sure
really about all this but I didn't like
this alternative there
check so I think I should be okay yeah
not not sure I better or anything but it
shouldn't be bad check
okay if I take this it's no check first
and foremost so I can theoretically
speaking I could even take 1c3 here I
just this you cannot take care for
anyway
my position doesn't feel so coordinated
it looks very nice with the two bishops
but I have some coordination issues the
night or e6 is very very annoying
check
nice could put this chick here coming
and rope here rookie a rookie seven text
text and maybe 95 million this is a very
cheeky but might work hmm ok I'm clock's
ticking down check have to go for
something
quantix I guess all i see doing
something Knight takes especially for
don't know about that one
96 I'm just blundering stuff this is
frustrating just just doing those one
movers that give away the whole games
that's just bad oh my goodness blah
resigns ciao the [ __ ] was training
after the opening too young this is
really nice for black but I made
mistakes yeah definitely this is a
mistake for example and not difficult to
see actually that I have to take here to
avoid this Bishop e3 business and this
is just very nice for black actually and
we get we get this it's very very
similar to the game in some way but the
difference is that here and there I
didn't need to lose any time there with
93 and so on and here I'm just I mean
after porn but i also have pressure
against this of course um he's got
chances to draw him with the opposite
colored bishops but i'm very one
silently pressing for a win here and
here i mean okay that's not bad but it
was reasonably come come complicated
check term patent didn't play it well
yeah yeah this is indeed i wanted to go
here but the problem is that that is
good i thought this is the issue maybe i
can go see six
that wasn't a huge problem this is a
business problem now that position is
already not so great I think okay the
engine wants to do this and Tess equal
okay I'm a bishops I'm not doing that
much here this is a problem check and of
this is it's two loops position it's
very loose I have to rely on tactics
like that since the engines line quite
funny with equal play but yeah can sound
very realistic this is terrible ga just
idiotic and still I mean okay i'm
clearly bursaries and probably losing
I'm losing you but you can at least
still continue and now I Knight f6 it's
just it's just embarrassing okay thanks
for watching